ah non non non je ne suis pas mis l'un
est d'abord j'aimerais dire que avant
cette affaire j'avais pas regardé les
vidéos avant que de savoir qu'on allait
en parler ici parce que je me suis dit
quelle est la portée d'une jeune femme
de 16 ans jeune fille qui tient des
propos peut-être haineux est ce qu'on a
besoin de s'indigner de tous
systématiquement est ce qu'on doit
prendre avec le même degré de haine ces
paroles que c'est un ministre pour avoir
ou un journaliste je pense qu'il faut
aussi faire attention et j'appelle les
gens sur les réseaux à ne peut-être pas
surréagir systématiquement dès qu'il
voit quelque chose qui pourrait les
blessés parce que finalement tout ça et
se retourne un peu contre la cause qu'on
voudrait défendre initialement alors moi
je ne suis pas mis là ça ne veut pas
dire que je cautionne et que je suis
content qu'elle puisse être harcelé que
je suis satisfait qu'elle soit menacé
évidemment non en revanche on est dans
une forme d'hypocrisie absolue on nous
dit on à droit de critiquer les
religions et je peux le comprendre
dès qu'on ne peut pas critiquer les
religions du matin au soir que ceux sur
bfm sur lci sur ses news
on a des journalistes militants puisque
maintenant un droit de le dire qui
souvent des leurres qui est un fait
divers cherche à blasphémer les
musulmans pas plus ça qu'on veut les
calomnier les humilier et
systématiquement les mettre sur le
devant de la scène comme si les
musulmans était le problème numéro un en
france
néanmoins critiqué l'islam ce n'est
peut-être pas l'insulté et provoqué ce
torrent finalement de gens qui vont être
blessé je peux comprendre que certains
pourquoi doit-on porter le voile je
trouve ça absurde et le débat est
possible je peux comprendre les gens qui
disent mais pourquoi vous faites le
ramadan je peux comprendre
en revanche dire est que je suis désolé
si l'un d'entre nous sur ce plateau un
jour avait tenu ces propos
comme me l'a jamais nous ne sont servis
de la liberté d'expression pour dire ce
n'est pas grave c'est une alors je pense
que insulté blesser les gens ce n'est
pas une opinion
cyril je sais que tout ça c'est de la
sierra peut priver ce que je veux bien
mais vous et moi n'a pas la même
religion
et pourtant on est proche il répond ce
que vous faites c'est vrai ici c'est de
rassembler les gens on a besoin
d'entendre tout le monde partout là ce
qui se passe c'est que dans la tête des
gens ce qui est en train de se passer
on en train dissocier la façon dont on
traite les musulmans de la façon dont on
traite certaines d'autres communautés on
va dire mais regardez on va opposer les
uns aux autres et on va créer dans leur
tête
pourquoi est-ce que du matin au soir on
peut critiquer les musulmans alors que
ce qu'on s'attaque à une autre religion
on va être beaucoup plus sympas et je
pense que cette fracture là dans la
société
elle va naître de ce genre de propos ou
régulièrement on dit liberté
d'expression alors que simplement c'est
la liberté d'insulter l'islam on a eu le
monsieur sur lci qui avaient dit qu'ils
avaient comparé le voilà uniforme ss on
a et monsieur zemmour qui est comparé
l'islam au nazisme
on a eu 10 très rare le patron du figaro
qui explique que s'il avait une femme
voilée dans un bus il serait descendu du
bus
et là tout d'un coup ça passe en
revanche je pense que cette femme
il faut évidemment la protéger parce que
s'il est hors de question qu'elle soit
victime de ça mais quand je vois que
c'est une récupération politique et
quand je vois que derrière monsieur
castaner reprend madame belloubet en lui
disant oh là là c'est une catastrophe ce
qu'elle a dit j'aimerais que monsieur
castaner celui des manifestants qui
s'occupe un peu plus du problème des
policiers avant de donner dans une
démocratie aux autres